do you call or text friends family and
colleagues in different EU countries
good news because your phone bills and
those of millions of other Europeans are
coming down again the EU acts roaming
charges in 2017
now it's capping international calls
from your home to other EU countries and
where I have their worst result of
roaming but we stopped halfway now we
can say that it doesn't matter if you
call from your home to another European
country or if you are in another
European country and you want to call
home
exactamente no poder de cortar messi vs
innovate sentimos for minuto o
save 10 t mode for SMS esto significa
n-terminal generalís una opción muy
significative up the rules also mean it
becomes easier for people to monitor
their phone bills or change phone
provider while smartphone users benefit
from better security like mandatory
end-to-end encryption on messaging
services and as of 2020 mobile networks
will begin to get faster with the
rollout of high speed 5g as well as
bringing down the cost and improving
connectivity for phone users the new
rules make Europe safer a system known
as reverse one-one-two will alert people
of danger in the event of a terrorist
attack or a natural disaster